okay
Turkish flags have been raised up again
in the capital Ankara after a week of
national mourning for the tens of
thousands of people killed by two major
earthquakes in the southern region
opposition parties say much of the
distraction could have been avoided if
the government had heated warnings by
experts of an impeding quake
this video is from last summer it shows
an opposition politician in karaman
maharash the epicenter of last week's
earthquake
urging the authorities to take
precautions to minimize damage
all pointers of the opposition e party
has been visiting the quick affected
region and is accusing the government of
its late response he says the damaged
infrastructure which cut access to some
areas was also built by the current
government
it is a disaster that after 20 years of
governing as a single party you haven't
taken any necessary measures here
despite that there was an earthquake
three years ago there's no excuse
seeking accountability is another thing
but it's a systemic issue we'll solve
this all together though we don't have
time for reproach or descent
last week Turkish president
inspected the ongoing rescue and relief
efforts in all 10 cities affected by the
quick and acknowledged problems with the
initial response
we're dealing with this disaster with
common sense and Collective wisdom all
of our ministers especially our
president have regular contact with our
teams in the field we manage this
process based on field feedback and
consultations this is a collaborative
effort between our Ministries and
related organizations
all parties in the Turkish Parliament
including the governing Arc party have
mobilized their members to help the
victims
turkey is preparing for a presidential
election that is most likely the most
difficult for president rejected erdogan
who's been in power for more than 20
years last Monday's earthquakes will
almost certainly have political
ramifications for now both sides appear
to have suspended their campaigns as
they work to help Millions who've been
affected
Ankara